hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of infinity war Captain America
stuff is finally happening so I'll
explain what's going on this is a new
round of the Marvel giveaway going on
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so Anthony Mackie has been teasing that
he and Captain America have been doing
some Captain America specific infinity
war scenes recently at the big place
where they used to film all the Hogwarts
stuff during the Harry Potter movies
there's a whole lot of filming all over
the place that's going on in Scotland if
you've heard about the vision Scarlet
Witch stuff has they've been filming
that's in a different place in Scotland
but it's still in Scotland so this is
giant Harry Potter castles it just looks
so fantastic and otherworldly we'll talk
about that in a second but if you
remember zoe saldana teased that they
were going back at the end of the year
the guardians of the galaxy were going
back at the end of the year to film
scenes for the 4th Avengers film and
regardless of what the title is going to
be they're sort of mixing and matching
things from Thanos quest in the Infinity
Gauntlet so charting Captain America's
timeline and sort of where his story
picks up even though the stuff that
they're filming right now all this
Hogwarts stuff seems like it's happening
much later in the film so starting with
him at the end of civil war he breaks
out the rest of the former Avengers that
had been captured and were on the raft
they're sort of like Captain America's
Secret Avengers which was something that
happened during the Dark Reign period
when there was an official Avengers team
that was sponsored by the government but
it was being run by Norman Osborn and it
was basically a bunch of the
Thunderbolts a bunch of the villains
masquerading and using the titles of the
main heroes so obviously the movie has
changed a few things but there are
Avengers that are still doing Avengers
things even though they can't call
themselves Avengers while at the same
time you have your Tony Stark led
government-sponsored Avengers he left
Tony with that dinky little flip song
which I know is kind of stupid saying
that anytime you need me I will be there
even though they haven't reconciled
there's no way that tony is going to
forgive anyone for the death of his
mother overnight that's going to take a
lot of time they put Winter Soldier on
ice in Wakanda and Captain America was
the last scene there so naturally you
would think the next place that he would
show up along with the Winter Soldier
because those characters come hand in
hand would be during the Black Panther
movie but based on some of the stuff
that we saw during guardians of the
galaxy - I'm going to change a little
bit about the way that I think the
captain may
is going to pop up before the beginning
of infinity war as well as the stuff
that Thanos is doing so I'll say careful
for minor spoiler warnings it's not
really spoilery but I'll go ahead and
say that you know guardians of the
galaxy too happens Thor is the next
movie that's happening so naturally you
think there'd be a bit of crossover
during the end of the movie and there is
a very minor bit of crossover but not in
the way that you would expect and Kevin
Feige clarified that the reason that
Marvel movies don't crossover as much as
they used to like seeing Thor's hammer
in someone else's movie is is because
they don't have to like they know that
people are going to go see that next
movie
so they don't need to hijack one
person's movie just to set up stuff
that's happening in another movie
there's always post-credit scenes that
will do that but they're way less
invasive now than they were say during
Iron Man 2 which a lot of people point
to is a key example of a movie that they
try to stuff too many things into to set
up the rest of the stuff that was coming
at the end of phase 1 so lesson learned
James Gunn said the guardians of the
galaxy 2 was meant to be very
self-contained very little crossover
and I will say without giving away big
spoilers he was definitely correct there
are elements of crossover things that
tee up future movies but not in the
really heavy-handed way that you would
expect seeing that made Miriam Erica
Iron Man the other big crossover
characters like people that are a list
Avengers but don't necessarily have big
films coming up before infinity war so
as the end of civil war he's sitting
here in Wakanda with Black Panther that
doesn't necessarily guarantee that he'll
show up during the Black Panther movie
because if guardians of the galaxy 2 is
any guide then they'll just let Black
Panther be Black Panthers movie and if
there is Captain America Winter Soldier
stuff they'll only show up for like 10
seconds at the very end of the movie
like they won't be part of the Black
Panther story at all in as awesome as it
is the C cap it just sounds like they're
not going to hijack Black Panthers movie
to set up his arc characters it's not
really important for the Black Panther
movie at all going forward that might
change though but you also have other
movies like spider-man homecoming they
haven't said anything about Captain
America's presence they have the funny
gym tape the joke about him stealing his
shield oh I know that guy I totally
stole his shield this last summer but
again it just seems like that's going to
be the level of Captain America
involvement in spider-man
I'm coming so it sounds like the first
time we're really going to get a lot of
Captain America is going to be at the
beginning of Avengers infinity war which
is kind of the same thing for Thanos it
seems like because thanks to Zoe Saldana
we know they're splitting the Thanos arc
from Thanos quests in Infinity Gauntlet
into two different movies regardless of
what they call the fourth Avengers film
I play no poker anymore look at my poker
face I think I just got myself fired if
indeed I did I did slip and say the name
of the fourth movie so infinity war is
mostly Thanos collecting the gems
assembling the gauntlet in Tony putting
the Avengers back together getting the
band back together because they're all
very much broken up and he says that
even during the spider-man homecoming
movie cap is still very much on his
list
so I've done a couple videos about the
stuff that happened at the very
beginning of the Infinity Gauntlet comic
book the thing about that is that cap
actually doesn't have that much to do
like he's a big character on the
Avengers team but really the biggest
characters the ones that assembled the
team warned everybody about the threat
in that comic book where Adam warlock
Doctor Strange and then the Avengers
just got together they went to Asgard
they met with the Godhead to try and
figure out what was going on the Godhead
is just like the pantheon of all the
gods of all the big religions in the
Marvel Universe so it's like Odin and
the other gods they're a little bit
below the celestial constructs though
like Galactus but while the Thanos
storyline for infinity war is mostly
Thanos quest there were no Avengers in
that like it was literally just Thanos
going around collecting the gems so all
the Avengers coming together and
figuring out what they need to do about
the problem that happened at the
beginning of the Infinity Gauntlet comic
book so there's a lot of stuff getting
mixed and matched and once we start
seeing trailers and footage we can talk
about it in more specifics but it sounds
like what will happen is is you're like
briefly touch base with Captain America
things in roundabout ways like this
funny VHS tape in this movie then
they'll probably tag Bucky at the very
end of The Black Panther movie but
that's really about it so this whole
time cap will probably be trying to save
people on the DL being a secret Avenger
with the other people that are on the
lam while at the same time trying to
keep up with what Tony and the other
legit Avengers are doing right now but
like Nick Fury shows up during the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book we have
seeing Sam Jackson in the Marvel
Universe in a long time he keeps
complaining too he says that he went to
Kevin Feige before civil war and they're
like you're not in this one man he's
like well what am i doing now so they
told him that while Nick Fury was not in
the movies he was still very busy on the
DL trying to dismantle the rest of Hydra
all over the world so that's probably
what cap is doing while this is going on
trying to hide out Bruce Banner style
while at the same time doing good things
even though mostly Hydra has gone in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they've been
doing some stuff with them on agents of
shield but there's a little bit of
trickery involved with that so Hydra is
mostly God Red Skull is not though he
was just portal Dawei by the space gem
so he could always come back in the
future if they want him to in speaking
of future Captain America movies Chris
Evans did say that he was coming to the
end of his contract but he was totally
willing to resize and he did joke about
who would leave their contract first
like who would stop being in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe him or Robert Downey
jr. and he thinks that Robert Downey jr.
is going to leave before he does so if
you're worried about Captain America not
being Captain America in any of the
movies anymore do not freak out they
just might not do another solo Captain
America movie for a long time he'll just
pop up during other people's movies like
Captain Marvel in fact he was the one
that suggested to Captain Marvel that
she start using that title instead of
the traditional MS marvel that she'd
been using for most of her run they will
probably meet for the first time during
infinity war because that's supposed to
be the debut of her character but they
haven't really said whether or not
they're going to let her get her powers
during that movie or if they're going to
save that like the true origin story for
the Captain Marvel movie so we really
don't know where she's at as of infinity
war yet but let me know in the comments
what do you think the cap has been busy
doing this whole time with the other
Avengers there are outlaws right now
while all these other movies are
happening because most of them aren't
showing up in these other movies like
Falcon scarlet which we have ant-man and
the wasp coming up so they have to
address them but that movie is not going
to drop till after the first infinity
war film so bye infinity war it's
implied that the people that were
fugitives before will stop being
fugitives and they'll be able to walk
around in public again
so what will happen is I'll announce the
Marvel giveaway winner the next time I
post a Marvel video there's new American
Gods posting if I haven't already
posted it depending on when I finish
this video so why you wait for that you
can click here for a new thor ragnarok
and you can click here for brand new
splash thank you so much for watching
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video